former world champion gary kasparov is
joining us live on air
hello gary
well guys hi welcome where are you gary
resha
and how are you doing
fine fine so um
it's always nice to to to to watch the
games and criticize the players well
criticize the players you can do any
criticism for hikaru though
yeah uh look uh he car is it's a pity
car is not you know
so playing with the full uh full cycle
because uh his instincts are in blitz
and rabbit are still phenomenal
so but he's he's streaming down so i
think he just did see he found something
more exciting but when he when you move
the pieces you know wrap it in blitz
yeah it's still amazing gary quick
question for you when you think of great
blitz players and i'm going to accept
yourself because i think of you as a
great blitz player when you think of
really the greatest blitz players from
your career how would you compare magnus
as well as hikaru to the world's really
great blitz players and your in your
view
yeah it's uh it's a it's a tricky
question because it's it's not just
about blitz you know it's your speed you
know moving the pieces around but it's
also about the general knowledge and so
how you can you know play the openings
what kind of you know the selection of
ideas that you can imply on blitz but
but also don't forget when we play blitz
yes you know it's we haven't heard about
increment
right we played different blitz
so the big events big events in the 80s
and even 90s you know their events
without increments
so now it's it's it's quite a different
game so that's why i think automatically
you know just
projecting so uh
fischer
i don't know petroleum towel myself
karpov
um
even kramnik at his peak to
magnus and hikaru and ferugia i think it
would be
unfair
because of the increment a very special
story i remember was told
yes also about the openings you know
this is they they have they have much
broader selection of ideas that they can
they can they can uh employ for their
blizz games right i i was just going to
say a wonderful story was told that
michael tall was a hospital in moscow
and he was told that there was a blitz
tournament
at the central chess club in moscow he
got out of the hospital bed
he went to play blitz
[Laughter]
you remember the story uh gary i don't
remember the story it's the the only
correction it was not central chess club
it was another building in the center of
moscow and uh
and tal was you know it was not just in
it it was not just a hospital bed it was
his almost desperate because he died a
couple of months later
but uh a few months later so um but um
but his you know his
performance at the board was still
phenomenal so
he he did not do extremely well but he
won one game and it was my only loss in
the tournament
well that's very memorable
[Laughter]
yeah
i said one important game here one more
more because it was it wasn't quite a
marathon right yes it's this this and i
i you know i was first bored i was
second and i beat him in the match but
but in i think round four i you know i
suffered quite an unpleasant defeat
against against all this was
yeah it's gary we're getting uh set for
our next round of blitz is there a
message you would like to leave to our
viewers uh about the grand chess tour
look i think it's important that
grunch's tour is happening because you
know this year and last year that's that
was quite um
quite um quite a challenge for for the
game of chess and i think we're doing
fine it's very important that the
grandchild's tour um even with all the
challenges all the difficulties all the
setbacks with players you know not
not um
being able to make it you know for
natural reasons these days um
and and the organizers forced to to
impose the mass mandate but we are you
know we are in business and i think it
shows that there's there's demand
and i'm quite pleased that you know the
this event is taking place and
and uh
we are expecting uh quite quite an
increase in geography um
next year so the next year will be a
larger
um hopefully again we will be able to
organize
all the event as planned but it will it
will become
a truly truly
representative global chess network and
i think it's it has great future thank
you gary so much we're going to get back
to our round but it was wonderful to
join us thank you again
thank you
for watching as well
[Laughter]
criticizing too criticized joining us
nice thank you gary
okay guys absolutely that's what it's
all